Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 283. Dieses Mal mit gemerkter Nummer und wie immer mir, Markus Richter, ich versuche hier Ordnung reinzubringen in den chaotischen Haufen, der dieses Mal das Halbjahreszeugnis für die Ampelkoalition ist. Und es dauert ja total lange zu erklären, warum sich die Sendung heute mit was zu beschäftigt. Aber heute ist es wirklich ganz einfach. Wir haben eine Regierung. Die Regierung hat vier Jahre Zeit um Dinge zu tun. Zwei sind vorbei. Wir gucken, was bis jetzt gut geklappt hat. Und natürlich mit dem Fokus auf das Digitale. Und dazu sind heute hier Konz und Erdgeist, beides Sprecherinnen des Chaos Computer Clubs Deutschland. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Und außerdem Elisa vom Superlab. Hallo. Ein Labor für die feministische digitale Zukunft. Was genau ist das?
Genauer gesagt für feministische digitale Zukunft. Weil wenn, dann wollen wir schon mehrere davon haben.
Ja, es ist eine NGO, ein Zusammenschluss von Leuten, die die Welt anzünden wollen. Beides?
Na ja, neu, die ist auch schon wieder zehn Jahre alt.
Verwaltungsdenken, in Verwaltungsdenken war das gestern, glaube ich. Und da war, als die eingeführt wurde, wurde das eigentlich zumindest verbal explizit ausgeschlossen, dass dieser Unique Identifier auch auf andere Bereiche übertragen wird. Jetzt haben wir den Salat, sie wollen es doch machen. Und da gab es zumindest in der Koalition, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, wie die Arbeit da jetzt zu bewerten ist, zumindest wurde diese Debatte nochmal aufgemacht und die wurde jetzt aber so ein bisschen abmoderiert. Also noch haben wir das nicht abgewendet, noch ist dieser Persistent Unique Identifier tatsächlich vorgesehen.
Da stand sogar im Koalitionsvertrag, dass sie das nicht wollen, dass sie stattdessen ein vertrauenswürdiges, allgemein anwendbares Identitätsmanagement sowie die verfassungsfeste Registermodernisierung priorität hätten. Und dieses moderne allgemein anwendbare Identitätsmanagement ist genau die Möglichkeit, du kannst dir selber beliebige Identitäten allen möglichen Behörden im Einzelnen gegenüber ausstellen. Wenn die signiert werden vom Staat, bist du halt an der Stelle derjenige, kannst die zusammenführen, wenn du möchtest. Das funktioniert in anderen Ländern auch super. Ja, es ist quasi ein gelöstes Problem. Aber in Deutschland ist, wir wollen einfach einen Primarikie, der irgendwie deine Steuer-ID oder deine, wie war das auch mal, wie das Merkmal vorher gewesen ist, Nachname plus Geburtsdatum plus Geburtsort oder so.
Also wir brauchen irgendwie einen primären Identifier, damit wir, und ich weiß nicht mal warum, Also, ich überlege gerade, wegen der anekdotischen Evidenz, ich habe neulich die Prämie fürs Elektroauto beantragt. Und da wurden mir gesagt, dazu brauchst du eine Bund-ID. Und die Bund-ID kannst du total einfach haben, wenn du dein ELZ-Zertifikat hier hochlädst. Also das wird schon sozusagen sehr gut betrieben, dass man da, also ich glaube, es geht auch anders, aber ist halt so schön einfach.
Wird ja wieder zurückkommen, als Beispiele, was geht. Das zum Beispiel für die Kommunikation innerhalb der Bundesverwaltung muss man jetzt nicht auf irgendwelche Messager zurückgreifen, bei denen man nicht ganz sicher ist, sondern der Bund hat den Bundes-Messager auf Wire basierend rausgebracht, wo nach einigen Angaben 22.000 Mitarbeiter in den Behörden miteinander kommunizieren und wollen jetzt auch Personen außerhalb der Behörden erlauben, diesen Messenger runterzuladen.
Das war früher ja für Unterpersonen verbreitet als individueller Abenteuer. Die haben sich so auf Verwaltung nicht nur in Deutschland spezifiziert, kann man sagen.
Wire an sich gibt es glaube ich gar nicht mehr.
Für Privatleute?
Für Privatleute. Ich weiß nicht, ob es eingestellt ist. Es wird auf jeden Fall nicht mehr offensiv. Ich glaube, es gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Das ist ja eine Firmenlösung. Es widmet sich nicht mehr an End-User-Innen.
Ja, es ist ganz wichtig, dass es open source ist. Und in Zukunft auch wieder für die Bürgerin zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Für die Behördenkommunikation. Dann inzertifiziert. Weil bisher haben sie gesagt, per WhatsApp schreiben ist vielleicht keine gute Idee. Und ich denke, das ist wahr. Und betrieben wird der ganze Kram. Genau der Bundes-Cloud. Wir kommen jetzt wieder zu dem ITZ-Zug.
Was heißt das ausgedingst? Informationstechnik-Zentrum.
Das ist schon ein Blick nach.
Man kann sich schlimmere Abkürzungen ausdenken.
Es sind 4200 Leute, die da arbeiten.
Das ist eine Art IT-Dienstleister.
Genau. Was ja eine der Forderungen war, die wir den Koalitionären ins Stammbuch geschrieben haben, dass einmal Projektmanagement-Kompetenzen, woran es am größten gehapert hat, dass der Staat nicht besonders gut war, IT-Projekte und IT-Großprojekte schon gar nicht zu begleiten, weil ihnen dort einfach die Kompetenz fehlte. Dem sind sie mit dem ITZ auf der einen Seite schon mal ganz massiv entgegengetreten. Sie haben dort für typische Informatik-Studenten ganz lukrative Angebote. Sie sind sehr stolz, dass sie fast 600 Millionen Euro an Leistungsprämien an ihre 4200 Mitarbeiterinnen ausgezahlt haben über das letzte Jahr. Sie gehen dahin und sagen, wir sind total geile Arbeitgeber, wir wollen Digitalisierung und drücken da grad voran. Aber dann siehst du, das Ergebnis ist, dass die jetzt in den 25 Rechenzentren, die sie in Deutschland haben, kannst du mal schätzen, wie viele Rechner sie da stehen haben?
25 Rechenzentren? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Wie viele ist so schön in jedem Rechenzentrum?
Wie viele Rechner hat ein Rechenzentrum? So viele, wie du denkst.
Und jetzt nicht riesige Rechenzentren.
Was?
Wie viele 25? Also 25.000?
Die haben so 55.132 Server stehen. Und wie viele Endgeräte bespielen sie damit?
Du meinst Leute, die da dransitzen? Na, pro Server ein User.
Zwei schaffen sie. Also sie haben 124.000 Endgeräte und dazu noch mal 27.000 ultramobile Endgeräte. Und Tablets, genau. Also das heißt...
Ultramobiles Endgerät, geil!
Ja, gut, aber die Frage ist, sind ITZ natürlich älter als die Ampel? Habt ihr jetzt für wahrscheinlich alle vermutet.
Aber stopp. Muss man so sagen, Zwischenschritt. Bei ganz vielen Dingen, die ihr sagt, sagt ihr jetzt so, na ja, aber es kommt ja eigentlich von vorher. Jetzt muss man glaube ich fairerweise die Frage stellen, hätte es denn die Gelegenheit gegeben, Dinge maßgeblich, also oder andersrum, hätte es hier eine theoretische Situation geben können, die positiv ist aus Perspektive des Clubs, wo man nicht sagt, das ist aber schon eine ganze Wahl in der Mache.
Ich glaube genau dort ist eins der Beispiele, wo man sieht, dass die Koalition das verstanden hat, dass es wichtig ist, Geld hingeworfen hat. Daher ist es eins von den Dingen, die...
Also bestehendes Konzept, aber sie haben es dann sozusagen weiter an.
Ich hab euch Zähne knirschend, ich will ja jetzt nicht die Regierung hier lob hudeln. Bei manchen muss man einfach sagen, Kritik da, wo Kritik angemessen ist, und dort sehe ich, dass das Geld und die Aufmerksamkeit an der richtigen Stelle landet. Es ist halt genauso, wie man sich so was wünschen würde für langweilige kritische Infrastruktur. Also, ich benutze dieses Wort kritische Infrastruktur, umpassend. Aber für Infrastruktur, die der Staat erst mal braucht, um zu funktionieren, das soll eigentlich nicht shiny sein. Das soll einfach funktionieren. Und dort sollen genau die Leute hin, die Lust daran haben, Infrastruktur zu basteln. Da sollen genau die Leute hin, die jetzt nach ihrem Studium für Systemintegration irgendwo gerne auch für Behörden und dann am Ende wieder den Bürger, der da mit der Regierung interagieren muss oder mit der Verwaltung. Da sollen funktionierende IT-Systeme stehen, die einfach nur funktionieren. Die müssen nicht die aller...
Also das klingt für mich so ein bisschen so an einer grundlegenden Basis. Infrastruktur wird gearbeitet und der Rest lässt noch zu wünschen übrig?
Sie haben da auch ein paar Werte umgesetzt. Die machen sich ein bisschen Gedanken um Nachhaltigkeit, Berechenzentrum, die machen sich Gedanken um freie Software. Also da sind ein paar Sachen, die wir lange fordern, dabei. Da kann man sich drüber freuen.
Zwei Jahre ist ein sehr kurzer Zeitraum. Wir sehen, dass dort bewusst Entscheidungen in die richtige Richtung weichgestellt werden, wo es nach zwei Jahren, du schon siehst, dass es in die richtige Richtung geht, aber natürlich noch nicht so weit ist, dass wir jetzt auf der Straße feiern würden.
Aber genau, es klingt für mich so, also die technische Basisinfrastruktur, also die Hardware, das ist ein bisschen falsch sozusagen, aber doch die Infrastruktur sozusagen, da wird der richtige Weg gegangen. Aber bei allem, wo es dann so ein bisschen inhaltlich, wo gesellschaftliche Konzepten eine Rolle spielen, wie zum Beispiel eine übergreifende ID in der Kontaktverwaltung sozusagen, da ist noch so ein bisschen...
Man muss die Ehrlichkeit halber sagen, klar, eine Bundesregierung kann nicht alle Stellschrauben stellen. Wir haben ja hier nur auch viele Landesgesetze. Wir haben eine sehr, sehr starke Kommunen, die ja auch eigene rechtliche Möglichkeiten haben und so weiter. Man sollte auch nicht überbetonen in einem föderalen Staat, was eine Bundesregierung kann. Deswegen würde ich jetzt... Also da werde ich dich so furchtbar stregen.
Das klingt jetzt für mich als gäbe es sozusagen im Zeugnis bei Open Source und Digitalisierung der Verwaltung vielleicht sogar eine 2? Oder was sagt ihr?
Ja, also ich bin auch nicht so unzufrieden.
Wir haben eine Sache komplett ausgeklammert und das ist ein anderer Arm, das...
Open Data meinst du?
Nicht Open Data, nee, sondern tatsächlich den ganzen Gerichtsbereich. Und da gab es tatsächlich zwei ganz spannende Sachen, die auch im Koalitionsvertrag standen. Das eine war eine Novellierung der CW-Prozessordnung, dass Videoverfahren jetzt quasi noch mal erleichtert werden. Da geht es zum einen darum...
Wo man nicht in Gerichtszeit ist, sondern wo man auch Video callen darf.
Das betrifft aber nur bestimmte Prozesse. Da sind wir noch in der Mitte, da wissen wir aber noch nie, wer draus kommt. Also da gibt es einen Entwurf.
Ich dachte, das wäre beschlossen. Aber vielleicht bin ich da, das ist nicht mein Expertenbereich, aber genau. Und das andere ist der Digitalcheck für Gesetze. Also quasi zu gucken, ob Gesetze, die natürlich von Menschen mit Juha-Kompetenz verfasst werden, auch aus Perspektive von Digitalkompetenz überhaupt tragfähig sind, oder dass eine Art von Standardcheck durchgeführt wird, auch nicht verkehrt.
Ich hab noch was vergessen, was ich beeindruckend fand, was irgendwie auch fast der Durchrettung, die Koalition ist angetreten mit der Ansage, wir wollen ein digitales Gesetzgebungsportal schaffen, über das einsehbar ist, in welcher Phase sich welche Vorhaben befinden. Die Webseite hab ich geklickt, war beeindruckend.
Okay, also ich schreib eine 2 auf, das ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht.
Na ja, man ist halt hinten losgerannt, come on. Wir waren halt nicht gerade vorne.
Willst du jetzt bei der 2 bleiben oder nicht?
Ich kann mich über, kann ich mitleben.
Ja gut, aber wenn die Leute mit Lernschwierigkeiten auch mal was hinkriegen, ist das doch gut. Vor allen Dingen, weil ja gute Lehre anscheinend da war. Ich erinnere mich an das Abschreiben vom... Ich musste wirklich entschuldigen. Das ist wirklich mega über den Kamm geschert, aber auch der Zeit geschuldet. Ich hab jetzt noch so einen Blog, den nenne ich moderne Zeiten. Und der hat damit zu tun, also Frau Merkel, 16 Jahre, ältere Personen. Ich darf nichts gegen ältere Personen sagen, da würde ich mich selber meinen. Jetzt neue Regierung, also neue Parteien, zum Teil an der Macht, neue Koalition, neue Menschen. Es gibt ja so ein paar Themen, über die wird jetzt schon mehr diskutiert als in den 16 Jahren Merkel. Das könnte man, glaube ich, ganz kurz zusammenfassen mit Vogue-Agenda. Also Klimakrise bekämpfen, Diversität, Gleichheit in der Gesellschaft, Nachhaltigkeit, diese ganzen Dinge. Da ändert sich ja auch alles, also auch der Club zum Beispiel. Die Diskussion zum Digitalen ist nicht mehr nur die Diskussion, fließen da irgendwie Safe-Nullen und-Einzen und kann das jemanden abhaben, sondern ist ja eben auch sozusagen diese digitale Infrastruktur, die wir hier gebaut haben, die wir alle benutzen, die wirtschaftlich und politisch motiviert ist. Wie verhält die sich zu den Themen? Die Schlagzeilen sind immer sozusagen, wie viel Kilowattstunden verbraucht eine Open-AI-Anfrage und wie diskriminierend sind eigentlich die neuen KI-Algorithmen und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen möchte ich das so breitfassen und fragen, ist davon was in den digitalen Aspekten des Koalitionsvertrags zu sehen? Da würde mir sozusagen, um ein Beispiel rauszugreifen, auffallen, wenn ich sozusagen eine Koalition wäre, die jetzt irgendwie eine Regierung würde, würde ich festschreiben wollen, dass bei Technologien, vor allen Dingen bei digitalen Technologien, die zum Bürgerkontakt sind oder den Menschen großzügig ausgesetzt sind, dass darauf hingearbeitet werden muss, dass ein Kriterium ist, dass die diskriminierungsfrei funktioniert. Weil das einfach so ein ganz großes Ding ist. Also, was meint man damit? Irgendwie ganz banales Beispiel, automatische Wasserhahnsensoren, die nicht mit dunklen Hautfarben funktionieren. So, das übersetzt in KI, Biometrie.
Das ist einfach so ein lebenswertliches Beispiel.
Um zu zeigen, worum es geht. Also Technologie sollte für alle Menschen, unabhängig von Hautfarbe, Geschlecht etc. funktionieren.
Wenn du diese ganze kulturelle Seite ansprichst, müssen wir auch noch mal sagen, dass wir nicht ahnen konnten beim Koalitionsvertrag, dass es einen unglaublichen KI-Hype geben würde. Mir persönlich ist schon auf jeden Fall, dass diese Fragen nach Vorurteilen nach Bias, also diese, was du jetzt so unter modern fasst, wie selbstverständlich mit debattiert wird. Also sie sind kein Non-Thema mehr. Das ist tatsächlich null für mich. Das habe ich sowohl auf der brüsseler Ebene, wie auf der deutschen Ebene früher als nicht so selbstverständlich empfunden.
Ja, ich sehe da trotzdem eine Lücke im Diskurs. Es wird drüber gesprochen, die Systeme, die Algorithmen in CM, da gibt es ja die lustigsten Begriffe, die diskriminieren jetzt. Und da müssen wir was dagegen machen. Ja, fair. Aber dass wir ja nach wie vor auch einfach Lösungen haben, die durch ihre Implementierung und die Art und Weise, wie sie umgesetzt sind, diskriminieren, ist auch ein Problem. Es gibt eine Studie vom Paritätischen Wohlfahrtsverband, der ganz spannend aufmacht, wie wohl sich Menschen in Deutschland mit digitalem fühlen. Also quasi wie confident, wie zuversichtlich die sind, digitale Services beispielsweise von Verwaltungen in Anspruch zu nehmen. Und da kommt raus, dass Menschen aus dem Niedriglohnsektor da wirklich, die haben vielleicht ein Endgerät, aber die sagen, sie sind nicht in der Lage, oder sie fühlen sich nicht im Stande, es stresst sie total, ein Online-Formular ausfüllen zu müssen.
Aber ist das Kulturei, das ist eine soziale Frage?
Das ist eine soziale Frage, genau. Das ist eine eminente soziale Frage. Aber da kommt Digitalisierung und am Ende Diskriminierungsfragen, haben wir da zusammen, und über diese Ebene debattieren wir nicht.
Ah, okay, das heißt, die soziale Komponente, die man dazu nehmen müsste, wenn man über diese Form der... Was machen eigentlich diese Rotzen, könnte man mal zuspitzen? Du meinst die normalige Arbeiterpartei? Das sind doch die Sozialdemokraten, die früher die soziale Frage gestellt haben. Und was ist denn mit Leuten, die sich kein 150-Smartphone oder auch kein 80-Euro-Smartphone leisten können? Wie ist es mit dem Zwang zur Digitalisierung? Also ich finde, das ist sehr weit aufgemacht.
Aber notwendig, wenn wir drüber reden. Das Querschnittsthema Digitalisierung ist halt dann leider auch echt ein Querschnittsthema.
Naja, vor allen Dingen sozusagen, weil wenn wir über die sozialen Klassen sprechen, ist es ja sozusagen, je schlechter es dir geht, desto weniger Zeit hast du ja und desto eher bist du darauf angewiesen, dass es vielleicht funktioniert, aber usw. Und so fort.
Also die sind trotzdem auch keine Nicht-Themen, würde ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt sagen. Aber ich finde, der soziale Komponente dieser progressiven Agenda ist am wenigsten ausgeprägt. Aus meiner Sicht, wenn ich mir so alle Debatten auch jetzt vielleicht noch ein bisschen Europa mit reinnehmen, aber bundesrepublikanisch so ansehe, da ist die, finde ich, noch am unterrepräsentierendsten.
Mein Verdacht ist ja, dass das damit zusammenhängt, weil man dann irgendwann sich fragen müsste, ob Kapitalismus wirklich die beste aller Ideen ist. Aber gut, ähm, an diesem Moment kommt man ja immer mal wieder im Chaosradio. Wie ist es denn mit der, mit der, also, oder um es anders zu sagen, also, es wird mitgedacht, es findet tatsächlich sozusagen eine Progressivierung statt, aber es gibt auch blinde Flecken.
Naja, die Zivilgesellschaftseinbindung ist natürlich ein Punkt, den wir dabei, also ich meine, wen bindest du ein, wen fragst du, und bindest du sie ernsthaft ein. Das steht auch im Koalitionsvertrag, ne?
Was denn?
Na, dass die Zivilgesellschaft besser eingebunden wird. Ich bin da super unzufrieden damit. Also zum einen, das hat so eine Goodwill-Komponente. Es ist oft auch zeitlich roter, knapp. Das hat man jetzt ja gerade wieder bei dem BND-Gesetz hier sehen. Albern wenig.
24 Stunden, 30 Minuten bei 88 Seiten.
Aber es ist auch so ein bisschen...
Also, Gesetzgebungsprozesse.
Ja, Zivilgesellschaft wurde eingebunden.
Lass mich kurz erklären. Da werden auch immer Expertinnen befragt. Das passiert auch schon weit vorher. Manchmal findet man ja ein Gesetz des Texten, nicht nur Dinge vom Chaos Computer Club wieder, sondern auch von möglicherweise reichten Industriezweiten.
Wirtschaftsverbänden?
Wird möglich, also vielleicht. Es gibt aber den einen Punkt, nämlich bevor das Gesetz in die parlamentarische Beratung geht, wo man gesagt hat, liebe Zivilgeschäfte, wollt ihr vielleicht auch was dazu sagen, dazu wird der Gesetzesentwurf verschickt. Und dann wird gesagt, so, jetzt habt ihr x amount Zeit und verhaltet euch mal dazu und schickt eine Stellungnahme. Das heißt, jemand, der fachlich kompetent ist, muss diesen Gesetzestext lesen und muss dann was zurückschreiben. Muss das aber auch so schreiben, dass es Leute lesen, die nicht unbedingt auch so tief drinstecken wie die Leute, die jetzt gerade das Gesetz gelesen haben. Und dafür ist natürlich zu sagen, liebe Leute, wir brauchen das morgen, relativ knapp. Das ist so ein Feigenblatt. Man hat im Genüge getan. Die Zivilgesellschaft war ja angefragt. Was können wir denn dafür, wenn die nicht...
Wen fragst du? Wer ist klassischerweise unterrepräsentiert? Wir wissen ja auch, wer sich in dieser Zivilgesellschaft engagiert. Und wer das nicht kann, welche gesellschaftlichen Gruppen da überhaupt nicht repräsentiert sind. Für mich ist es halt auch eine kulturelle Frage, weil diese Grünen als Teil der Ampel genau aus diesen Bewegungen kommen. So sind die geboren, wenn man jetzt mal die Jahrzehnte und die Parteientwicklung sieht. Und ich hätte einfach gedacht, es ist ein stärker Teil von deren DNA, dass die da anders drüber denken.
Wobei das Spannende ist, es gab ja solche Konsultationsverfahren, wie du sie gerade beschrieben hast, Markus, zu anderen Eckpunkte Papieren gibt es das Vorhaben, die viel stärker erstens angekündigt wurden. Das heißt, wir konnten uns alle schon mal emotional sammeln und irgendwie uns einlesen. Und dann gab es da Konsultationsfristen von drei Wochen oder so. Damit können wir ja arbeiten. Aber das Spannende ist doch wieder, bei welchen Gesetzen es nicht gemacht wird. Das ist halt wieder Überwachung.
Geheimdienste sind sowieso... Na gut, da könnte ich jetzt schon wieder den Rant ablassen, aber bei Geheimdiensten ist es ja sowieso anders. Ich habe da ein gewisses Enttäuschungsgefühl. Vielleicht war aber auch meine Erwartungshaltung einfach zu groß. Ich habe immer so ein bisschen gedacht, dass es jetzt auch eine gewisse kulturelle Änderung gibt.
Kann ich nachvollziehen, wenn eine ehemalige Arbeiterpartei mit einer Macht ist und den Kanzler stellt den... Anyways, das ist ja der eine Punkt, was ich jetzt muss schon langsam anfangen, sozusagen Tempo zu machen, um den Koalitionsvertrag zu zitieren. Was ist denn mit der Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte? Wird sowas auch überlegt? Bundeszentren sollen auf Ökostrom betrieben werden. Vielleicht guckt man auch mal, ob man Energie... Also wenn man schon Code selber beauftragt, dass der irgendwie energieeffizient funktioniert.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hätte mir nicht träumen lassen, dass die Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte so derart polarisiert wird. Ich hätte mir nicht träumen lassen, dass wir sozusagen eine ganze rechte Bubble haben, die im Wesentlichen diese Klima- und Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte derart stark politisiert. Ich hätte mir das einfach nicht träumen lassen. Da hat sich innerhalb von einem Jahr oder anderthalb Jahren unglaublich viel zum Schlechten gewandelt. Es gibt eine ganze Bevölkerungsschicht, die Nachhaltigkeit als Bedrohung empfindet. Auch da ist diese ganze soziale Frage viel zu wenig adressiert. Es ist völlig defensiv geworden. Ich muss den Heizhammer noch mal ansprechen. Ich glaube, ohne diese ganze Kampagne gegen einige Gesetzesprojekte der Ampel kennen wir diese Form von Popularisierung nicht. Ich habe den Eindruck, die riechen jetzt irgendwie schlecht.
Was du gerade machst, ein Kommentar zur generellen Politik. Was ich ja frage, ist, macht die Ampel-Regierung in ihrer Digitalstrategie oder in ihrer Digitalpolitik Spielt da Nachhaltigkeit und Energieeffizienz eine Rolle?
Also wir sind mit dem Schlagwort Green IT auch angetreten. Was sie jetzt umsetzen, die Rechenzentren, die sie selber betreiben, sind alle mit 100 Prozent Ökostrom betrieben, haben sie auf die Fahne geschrieben. Unter dem Stichwort Green IT könnte alle googeln, was die sich vorgestellt haben, welche Lösungen sie dort finden können und was sie tatsächlich umgesetzt haben. Aber das ist immer nur ein Teil dessen. Du kannst natürlich als Staat mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen, aber wenn du trotzdem sowas, was uns ja ganz wichtig war, dass es so Mindesteilbarkeitsdaten für Geräte laden, dass du nichts mehr verkaufen darfst, was nicht reparierbar ist, wo nicht Sicherheits- und Softwareupdates, wie kein Cloud-Zwang, also dass du keine Dinge verkaufen darfst, ohne selber zu garantieren, dass wenn es eine Cloud-Komponente gibt, du die weiter betreiben kannst, das steht alles nirgendwo drin. Wie die ganzen Dinge, die machen, dass in großen Mengen Elektroschrott anfällt, hat sich nichts bewegt, das ist traurig. Und in anderen Bereichen hat sich aber Dinge bewegt, wo der Staat mit eigenen Rechenzentren und eigener IT vorangeht. Da ist Nachhaltigkeit schon mehr gedacht.
Dieses ganze Gebiet klingt für mich wirklich nach einer 3.
Das ist ein Mienenfeld geworden. Und es ist so unsachlich geworden in vielen Bereichen. Wenn man das mal wirklich gesellschaftsverändernd umsetzen wollte, wurde das sofort so ein krasses Politikum innerhalb der Ampel. Und das ist für mich ein Hemdschuh. Mich nervte tierisch, dass diese Nachhaltigkeitsfragen kein Konsens mehr sind.
Man sagt ja manchmal auch, der größte Hebel ist das Vergaberecht. Der Staat investiert Milliarden im Jahr in Geräte, vergibt Aufträge für die Entwicklung von Softwarelösungen, für die Wachtung und so weiter. Und da noch mal mit reinzugehen und da Nachhaltigkeitsaspekte auch nach oben zu setzen auf der Agenda, ist ein Hebel. Und ich glaube, da sind sie auch dran. Aber ich weiß tatsächlich nicht, wie der Stand aktuell ist. Bei Vergabe heißt es üblicherweise, das Billigste muss genommen werden, außer wenn triftige Gründe dagegen sprechen. Und da halt vielleicht auch zu sagen, Nachhaltigkeit ist immer ein triftiger Grund, um sich gegen das Billigste zu entscheiden. Das wären relativ einfache Maßnahmen, die wir tragen, ohne dass man dieses Minenfeld betreten muss, weil das rein intern funktioniert.
Da machen wir auch wieder riesengroße Bereiche noch mit auf, weil mit Vergabe könnte man auch gleich sagen, dass die Software nicht mehr gekauft wird, wenn so eine Firma regelmäßig auffällt, dass ihre Software Bugs hat, die nicht gefixt werden. Oder dass sowieso keine Prozesse implementiert werden. Da gibt es viele Bereiche, wo der Staat einfach allein durch Einkauf auch richtige Impulse setzen könnte.
Was es denn eure Not dafür ist?
Du hast schon drei gesagt. Würde ich erschlössig mich an.
Das war jetzt nur eine Vermutung.
Ja, es ist auch kein Nicht-Thema. Ich finde schon, dass das auch bei der Vergabe eine größere Rolle spielt. Aber die Vergabe ist natürlich auch nicht nur bundespolitisch. Muss man wieder einschränkend sagen, wir sind nur mannförderer an der Stadt. Aber ich würde dann auch mit drei Kürtig leben.
Das führt uns jetzt schon zum Endsport. Weil dann sind wir bei der Durchschnittsnote von 3,4. Also 3 minus, könnte man sagen. Das wiederum finde ich jetzt fast schon ein bisschen überraschend gut. Weil eine 3 ist ja kein Totalausfall. Das ist halt so gut für die wenige Energie, die ihr da investiert habt. Das ist ein ganz passables Ergebnis eigentlich. Wie zufrieden seid ihr denn so insgesamt? Ich muss schon zugeben, ich hatte an einer Stelle das Gefühl, bei dem Verwaltungs- und Open-Source-Kram da kann man schon Bemühungen erkennen auch. Aber der Rest war eher so, naja...
Die Frage ist, ob die Bemühungen in die richtige Richtung gehen. Und da war bei uns da oben eher hoch. Also, Bemühungen tun sich ja immer...
Lass mich die Frage anders stellen. Auf dem Halbjahres-Zeitung steht eine Drei-Minus. Und es gibt ja noch zwei Jahre.
Wird versetzt, willst du fragen?
Ah, ja, aber nicht politisch. So läuft es aber nicht in der Legislatur.
Lass mal den Markus fragen.
Was ich fragen möchte ist, für die nächsten zwei Jahre weiter so? Oder ihr müsst grundlegend an folgenden Dingen arbeiten?
Ja, natürlich. Ich meine, wir reden seit Beginn der Koalition über das Digitalbudget, das wir bis heute nicht verabschiedet haben. Und wenn das jetzt noch kommt, dann sind da natürlich irgendwie Freunde drin. Ich finde das prinzipiell nicht verkehrt, aber dann haben wir tatsächlich...
Wofür soll das sein, das Digitalbudget?
Das soll tatsächlich diesen ganzen Digitalbereich eigentlich komplett finanzieren.
Insbesondere 18 Leuchtturmprojekte.
Aber die gibt es ja.
Das können wir jetzt aber nicht genauer aufmachen, oder?
Aber das müssen sie definitiv machen.
Wir haben noch irgendwie eine Vogelperspektive, die wichtig ist.
Warte, stopp. Forderung eins. Extra-Posten für Digitalprojekte im Bundeshaushalt.
Das Digitalbudget, das verhandelt wird jetzt endlich auch verabschieden. Und nicht wieder vertragen.
Warum, was tippst du jetzt nicht? Willst du das nachher hinschicken oder schicken?
Entfielst du das jemandem?
Ich treffe morgen den Olaf. Lieber Herr Scholz, Sie haben sich ja bis jetzt noch nicht auf der Tanzfläche gezeigt. Hier sind Ihre Karten, bitte umsetzen.
Müssen wir noch ganz kurz ansprechen, dass wir jetzt nicht realistisch noch zwei Jahre Zeit haben, sondern nur eins.
Ja, danke schön. Denn irgendwann geht es wieder in den Wahlkampf über. Die haben ja immer, also legislativ, wenn du da tätig werden willst, ein kleinerer Fenster als die gesamte Legislaturperiode.
Da ist ein Hauen und Stechen drin. Versuch mich ein bisschen aus der Fähre zu ziehen. Das ist ja beim Endjahres-Teugnis immer so. Die Sommerferien wird ja nicht zum Anfang der Sommerferien.
Nein, aber du musst Gesetzesentwürfe eigentlich jetzt, also jetzt und ein paar Wochen, dann ist es vorbei.
Und es ist ja schlimmer als Sommerferien, sondern dann geht ja diese komische Klientelpolitik wieder los mit den Ressourcen, die noch da sind. Dann wird es ja immer so ein bisschen irrational alles. Das wollen wir ja eigentlich eben verhindern.
Dann haben wir auch noch den Europawahlkampf und jetzt sind noch Hessen und Bayern. Also die Wahlkämpfe sind ja auch nicht nur im Bund. Im Prinzip ist das jetzt schon mit Entzeugnis.
Wenn du den Olaf morgen triffst, geh mal daher und sag Olaf, deine Vorgängerin hat was von Neuland gefaselt. Du könntest jetzt mal hergehen. Ich als digital native würde mir jetzt wünschen, dass die Gesellschaft sich auf die Fahnen schreibt, selber weiterzubilden im Digitalen, die Möglichkeiten wahrzunehmen, sich weiterzuentwickeln, souveränen mit dem umzugehen. Dafür ist doch genau so ein Bundeskanzler da.
Was du machst, ich wollte gerade sagen, das klingt nach einem Heißluftballon. Was meinst du? Was soll die Ampelregierung machen?
Du wolltest mit Olaf dich treffen und ich dachte, du könntest ihm sagen...
Ich rede mit dem Tacheles, keine Politiker-Phrase.
Ach so, sind die Türen zu? Ich hab jetzt die Merkel, die sich hingestellt hat und meinte, dass es für uns alle Neuland und damit eine Entschuldigung für viele geliefert hat, sich mit diesem ganzen Digitalgedüns nicht auseinanderzusetzen. Dem gegenüber würde ich gerne an der Spitze des Staats, na gut, zumindest an der Spitze der Regierung, irgendjemanden entgegenstellen, der mal sagt, nee, das ist alles nicht so, wir müssen das als Hochtechnologieland, müssen wir wie selbstverständlich damit umgehen. Der Fisch stinkt doch dann immer vom Kopf her. Wenn dort Leute stehen, die ihm wie rumwabern und mit dem Digitalen nichts zu tun haben wollen, dann siehst du das auch in der Gesellschaft. Das heißt, sag dem Olaf, der soll mal irgendwie auch ganz selbstverständlich von seinem selbstgemastelten PC berichten oder so. Ich möchte eine positive Vision formulieren, wie eine Regierung neben der Gesetzgebungskompetenzen, die sie haben, auch durch Vorbildwirkung...
Guck, dass du nichts mit Worten machst. Ich schreib mal auf, Selbstverständlichkeit der digitalen Perspektive. Was? Deine Forderung für die Zeit nach dem Halbjahreszeugnis formuliere ich jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig.
Ich glaube, dass ein Schlüssel noch ein paar Sachen hinzukriegen ist, also hat mit der Zivilgesellschaft zu tun. Und eines ist Wissen und Sachkenntnis über viele Bereiche und auch Analysen. Gibt es eine Menge. Und die Frage ist immer, wen man für was heranzieht. Also was jetzt noch kommt an Gesetzentwürfen und tatsächlich Entscheidungen, die noch durchgezogen werden kann, da würde ich mir insbesondere wünschen, dass eine größere Breite der Zivilgesellschaft beteiligt wird. Ich hätte das für essentiell. Und auch für einen progressiven und kulturell modernen Agenda verwichtig. Und das Zweite ist... Aber auch tatsächlich beteiligt, oder? Lass mich dir noch mal kurz denken. Was ich mir so wünschte, ist, sich in gewisser Weise dieser ganzen Wissenschaftsfeindlichkeit die krasiert so entgegenzustellen und diese Sachliche mir in den Vordergrund zu stellen. Und auch mal gegen Wirtschaftsinteressen. Also ich meine, den Mut zu haben fände ich wichtig. Aber ich sehe den, wenn ich ehrlich bin, natürlich jetzt wenig. Also ein paar Entscheidungen, die jetzt anstehen, auch im Digitalen, wären halt eher so teuer. Und nicht unbedingt so populär sein, weißt du so? Na ja, insbesondere bei den Überwachungsfragen, die wir am Anfang hatten. Das ist ja so, das wird nicht unbedingt populär sein. Ja, überleg dir doch mal.
Was wird daran teuer, nichts zu überwachen?
Ach so, das meine ich jetzt mehr so bei der Digitalisierung. Klar, wenn man da unabhängig und nachhaltig agieren will, ist das nicht unbedingt die billigste Variante. Weiß nicht, ich hätte halt manchmal die Hoffnung, dass sie ein bisschen mehr gegen den Stachel locken und so ein bisschen auch den Mut hätten, ihre Ideen davor zu tragen. Aber innerhalb der Ampel sind sie sich ja leider auch nicht einig. Oh Gott, jetzt bin ich aber wieder sehr, oh boah, jetzt hab ich echt weit ausgeholt, tut mir leid.
Ja, ich bin interessanterweise jetzt am Ende der Sendung nicht ganz hoffnungslos, aber schon so ein bisschen...
Das wollten wir nicht.
Zynisch?
Naja, ne, ne, ne. Es gibt das schöne englische Wort jaded. Das ist sozusagen, das beschreibt noch besser, also zynisch und gleichzeitig abgestumpft, also quasi froh, dass es immerhin eine 3,4 geworden ist. Und vielleicht wird es ja nicht sehr viel schlimmer.
Also eine Gymnasiallempfehlung gibts damit nicht, Versetzungsgefährdet ist aber auch nicht.
Na ja, vor allen Dingen, was droht uns, ihr gebt euch mal bitte die Wahlumfragen an, da werden wir noch fröhlich auf die Ampel zurückblicken. Hallo, wenn uns erstmal irgendwie CDU und AfD regiert.
Ich bin mir übrigens nicht ganz sicher, ob man dieses Mem verbreiten sollte. Weil, ja, es gibt sozusagen Schaubilder, die das zeigen. Aber das sind ja alles sozusagen statistische Dinge. Ich habe mich neulich sozusagen darüber aufgeregt, dass ein ehemals progressives Platt damit getitelt hat, ob es denn denkbar wäre, wenn jetzt so ein AfD-Typ Ministerpräsident ist. Und damit verschiebt man natürlich, deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob man das auch herbeireden kann.
Ich möchte es gar nicht herbeireden, keine Sorge.
Ich möchte es an der Stelle noch mal sagen.
Aber ich habe gerade noch mal einen Kommentar aufgemacht, den Markus Becke da auf messpolitik.org geschrieben hatte, als der Koalitionsvertrag ganz frisch rausgekommen war. Also der erste Kommentar dazu. Der Titel ist, Ampel verspricht Stärkung digitaler Grundrechte. Und da wird es doch spannend, weil wenn wir, ob der jetzt herbeigeredet ist oder wann näher passiert, das ist wahrscheinlich eher die Frage, in dieser ganzen zivilgesellschaftlichen Bedrohungslage, in der sich inzwischen echt viele in dieser Gesellschaft befinden, weil sie angegangen werden, weil sie gedoxt werden und so weiter. Haben wir da jetzt eine Stärkung unserer digitalen Grundrechte? I don't see it. Und ganz ehrlich, das bräuchten wir doch.
Dafür steht nur Buschmann, aber er hat halt keinen sehr starken Stand.
Na das ist ja schön.
Jetzt hast du aber auch herausgefordert, dass wir negativer werden.
Ich hab nur nach dem gefragt, was ist. Anyways, also liebe HörerInnen, es war sehr schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Wir nehmen Kommentare, ne? Also ihr könnt ja selber sagen, was ihr sagen würdet.
Ihr könnt gerne ein anderes Talknus aufstellen oder dasselbe unterstreichen. Ihr könnt sozusagen wie die Eltern unterschreiben, was wir hier gerade verurteilt haben. Oder nicht?
Sagen wir like und subscribe?
Like und subscribe, abonniert! Genau, trag die Kunde weiter. Drückt die Glocke. Drückt die, haben wir eine Glocke? Wir müssen eine Glocke auf eine Glocke einbauen, damit man auch die Glocke drücken kann. Erdgeist, Elisa und Konz, vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart. Und dass ihr schön auseinanderdividiert habt. Und ihr, liebe Hörerinnen, es bleibt mir vor allen Dingen heute wieder mal zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.